Now some of you may think that I'm exaggerating
when I say this November's elections are more important
than any I can remember in my lifetime.
In this election, we are fighting to win and
we are going to win.
Republicans and Democrats may genuinely hate
each other
but they love their own power even more.
That's why they collude so often to keep those
pesky Libertarians, Greens and Independents
away from the lucrative levers of government.
The 2018 midterms, like all campaign seasons,
have been chock full of two party shenanigans.
All too often aided and abetted by journalists,
pollsters and the voters themselves.
It all starts with ballot access.
If a state government considers you a major
party, getting on the ballot is a snap.
Worst case scenario, you need to collect signatures
from a tiny fraction of your own registered
voter base.
Best case you just show up-
How you doing?
-you're a major, party on.
Third party and independent candidates, on
the other hand,
have to collect tens of thousands of signatures
in some states.
Fifteen thousand to run for governor of New
York
including at least a hundred in each congressional
district.
In fact, Arizona Republicans recently changed
the law
to make Libertarians have to collect signatures
not just from their own voters
but from registered independents as well.
And by the way, that doesn't apply to the
Green party,
which means that in Arizona this year, in
the US Senate race which is neck and neck
there's a Green candidate but not a Libertarian.
Some states push their filing deadlines all
the way back to a year before the election.
That's one of many reasons why candidates
like Evan McMullen,
when they get a sudden itch to run for President,
are lucky to make it on even a dozen ballots.
New Hampshire this year herded all third parties
under the same ballot line
confusingly titled Libertarians and other
candidates.
New Mexico tried and thankfully failed to
institute a straight party ballot
meaning voters in this 3-2 Democratic state
could automatically vote for all the candidates
in one party by checking off just one box.
Gary Johnson's surging poll numbers I am sure
were purely coincidental.
Getting your name on the ballot doesn't mean
it's going to be included in the polls.
The Nevada race for US Senate for example
is universally rated a toss up
and yet the first three independent polls
released this October
did not include Libertarian Tim Hagan
even though previous surveys had him at about
4%.
How about the debates?
Pennsylvania Senate candidate Dale Kerns was
assured of a spot on stage and then uninvited.
If we can implement fresh ideas into the system,
they're going to have to change.
Texas gubernatorial candidate Mark Tippetts
was told he didn't have enough qualifying press
in part because his coverage in the Spanish
language media didn't count... in Texas.
All Texans have a right to hear from all of
the options
that will be on the ballot for governor this November.
Iowa governor candidate Jake Porter, who's
polling higher than any other LP statehouse contender,
says his debate invitations were rescinded,
in part because he refused to buy commercials.
'The freer and more general the competition'
Adam Smith wrote in 1776
'the more advantageous it will be to the public.'
Competitors, he warned, will always try to
widen the market and narrow the competition.
Our system of government, that other glorious
achievement from 1776
has for too long been controlled by the same
type of market rigging forces
that Adam Smith warned us about.
It's about time to make American politics
competitive again.